[Music]
oh
that was some on beat sipping
it's like very good mug
and he's orange that's a good siphon
eminem good for you uh we have a lot to
be talking about today we're going to
get into when people have talked about
the shadowy figure who is funding
some of these riots going on in the
country and saying it's not just it's
not a george soros plot
oh it's actually the president for the
president uh candidate uh presidential
candidate for the united states and his
vice president and his broad wow yeah
yeah
and then for the first time ever i have
changed my mind well i have to well yeah
but we have a segment coming up on
tesla's
yeah and why i've changed my mind to see
we'll also be talking about the recent
polls
but that'll be exclusively for mug club
uh so please do consider joining up at
loudoutwithcredit.com
mug club if not you can uh subscribe on
android apple and of course there's
crowder bits on youtube we will be
taking your live chat behind the table
hey my half asian lawyer bill richmond
is here how are you sir
this is caffeine free caffeine free i
know
what day high yeah just keeping it up
yeah no i'm normally not a caffeine guy
what day you are what is a cat what
what's what's the question how many days
in are you
i don't know it's not in the wagon you
dip well no
he's trying to make his life healthier
yeah you're looking you're trying to
ramrod the guy
i'm trying to encourage trying to
railroad him saying you're doing a great
job what dare you
you're trying to let's go to clip a
stroke violence the incumbent president
is incapable of telling us the truth
and capable of facing the facts and
incapable of healing
he doesn't want to shed light he wants
to generate heat
and he's stroking violence in our cities
stroking that violence he's stroking
violently in the in the corner
yikes that's a lot he wants to generate
heat
please that's what happens with stroking
stroke the friction generates heat
i read lord of the flies yes if you
don't get your hands on piggy's glasses
the poor son of a [ __ ] you're gonna
have to
use some friction and stroke yourself a
fight hey gerald morgan also known as a
father and i was here yes
i'm doing well good poor wife i hope
you're sleeping honey
yeah well that's this is how you would
get the message i like her
well she's not she at least knows that i
care and if she is she'll that was like
a performative prayer where someone's
like
dear lord we hope that
gerald is funnier today
uh he's not funnier well at least we
hope at least we hope dear lord
he can't demand things of the lord
don't you could provide but whoa again
whoa
make gerald funnier i don't want mud on
his eyes i can do i can do wonders with
scales
but uh not with humor uh quarter black
garrett is here
is a quarter black going on here's my
question of the day uh how dishonest do
you think it is for for the biden
campaign in harris biden and broad
biden and broad this honestly i think it
is for biden and broad to blame the
riots and violence right now on donald
trump that's been their new strategy
and how convincing do you think it is
because we went from total disavow
not disavowing sorry denying that
there's well it's that thing
burning uh behind you there i don't know
what you're talking about oh that's
trump
trying to jump to that yeah did that
yeah other than that i came and gave a
speech
donald trump didn't speak there he
skyped
he skyped somebody
um then 18 people were killed you know
and uh god knows how many rapes so this
is uh
this is rhetoric yes that was his
rhetoric
it was absolutely right he generates
heat he starts firing well
it's his general presence right yeah it
was it was that they dreamed about him
and then they had turned into a
nightmare and then it caused them to
burn buildings down
right you know that's just i followed it
it made sense yeah they think it's like
listen i just came from my boiler room
and
if i said in the national guard in your
dreams okay
they appear in real life that's true
it happens one church is coming for you
three
saying that and i said what is this
disgusting letter it's disgusting
can you believe that calling on her but
that's what some people say that's what
some people think
who had to tell them what to think uh
you wrote it to yourself mr president
uh it's true it is that does say that is
my handwriting
i guess i am stroking violence
uh here we go look coronavirus now third
leading cause of death in the united
states i do notice they didn't
they didn't update the death totals
there after cdc updated theirs
right well yeah they don't really care
so much they just care about the totals
they don't care about
how many they don't care about how many
lives are uh terminated due to
verifiably bad proactive nursing home
policies like listen
there's a lot of things there's a lot of
things that we don't know about the
coronavirus
i give you that that's why we haven't
been definitive and saying lockdowns
don't work and not having a lockdown
is a metric for the state being more
successful i haven't really made
affirmative arguments
on either side i've just encouraged
people to look at the data but one thing
we do
know is that sending patients with the
covid through nursing homes uh
pretty bad that's very very bad yeah you
can probably
put that one under unilaterally agreed
upon
don't send young sick patients into
nursing homes who have no business being
there
anyway do you think that's a factor as
to why we haven't seen andrew cuomo
very much oh no no no no no he wrote a
book just how i handled the crisis
but in the all the time that we've been
recently watching cnn and just kind of
like digesting media so that we can
translate it for uh the fans in the
audience
i'm not seeing a lot of interesting
things after he fired his lead medical
person who said that he was doing a
terrible job and he was like
terrible job terrible job do it on the
street bye out of here he's on a spirit
quest
it's for it's it's absurd yeah he's what
does he have
i hope you enjoy making your criticism
on the unemployment line
that's pretty much it there's no prisons
yes but they're literally with your
discarded nipple rings huh by the way
there's no there's so many nipple rings
there's no room for it all right as soon
as you were saying that like
you know nursing home cnn was saying
healthy people have died and i'm like
yeah
like ten okay i get it yeah like there's
statistically it's not ten it's a
statistically tiny number here's how you
get people who say you deny science by
the way with the chronovirus here's what
you do
it's very very easy i usually don't uh
you know a magician never reveals his
strengths
ah okay you say all right well listen
what percentage of uh the people who've
died have been young and healthy without
other
pre-existing conditions and usually they
eventually go out they go oh well it has
happened there have been look there's
190 000
there are people who are young and
healthy uh and some people have been
children you say
oh okay how many that's it they never
have an answer no
you win you take a knee three or four
anecdotal cases
and say see this tibo knee not a
kaepernick knee back one taking a knee
actually
you know you know i don't know do an
enzo dance just how many
i'll come back i'll check in later and
just walk out
they have nothing they can do let me
know if you got any numbers okay
again my question of the day is go ahead
i keep trying to get this go ahead
let me go i didn't do anything yeah you
did no you ruined my life
well that's true sorry it's really your
life i was speaking for you all i wanted
to say gerald is
i appreciate you oh nothing makes me
look funnier than being on the show
i do what i can this is sweet little uh
a little good cop bad cop little cop and
a half action going there we go
i prefer short round so uh yesterday
well we showed you that clip but uh
uh vice presidential camp vice president
now presidential candidate i don't know
how to be respectful
okay demented old circus monkey
[Applause]
made his biden on rioting across america
and i want i want to actually include it
with
here's something that is important
they've tried to blame of course donald
trump both
joe biden and kamala harris this is
their new strategy after denying that
violence had
been occurring actually it's worse than
that they encouraged it before
let's go to the clip of biden as well as
harris this president
long ago forfeited any moral leadership
in this country
he can't stop the violence because for
years he's fomented it
you know he may believe mouthing the
words law and order makes him strong
but his failure to call on his own
supporters to stop acting as an armed
militia in this country
shows how weak he is
does anyone believe there'll be less
violence in america
if donald trump is re-elected one
hundred percent joe speaks the words and
actually knows how to say the words
black lives matter contrary to what the
president says
and has never spoken those words and
will never speak the words black lives
matter
uh he did yesterday with laura ingram
but saying the term black lives matter
is so discriminatory
to joe biden just broke the first rule
of lawyering
which is probably why he never actually
served in the private sector beyond nine
months and they were like get rid of
that clerk with the hair plugs
he asked a question he didn't know the
answer to it's like does anyone think
that you will uh
do you honestly believe that uh you'll
be uh safer if uh
donald donald trump is re-elected yes
absolutely do you think uh you really
think i have dementia 100 percent
this is a bad line of questioning by the
way
the question trump's he called out
trump's
armed members do me a favor joe biden
show me the effing body count from them
and
let's compare that i have it so we have
over 700 million million dollars in
property damage really probably
approaching a billion we have a thousand
officers seriously injured
and ironically we actually have one more
person killed 19
officially killed by protesters than all
unarmed black men last year wow wow yeah
19 was 18 last year depending on the
sources you use i've read 18 or 19.
just really in three months and there
have been over 30 people killed at the
protest i'm talking about directly
killed
by protesters 19. so you guys
uh are worse than the systemic racism as
far as taking people's lives i know it
doesn't matter to you if there's not
quite the same level of melanin in the
skin but you're killing more people
look my thing is guys i just you know
how i feel about punching down and to
punch down at biden i mean the guy's got
he's got nothing up there yeah i mean he
does i wasn't going to
even realize that he's the one who's
fomenting the violence by saying yeah
it's fine i mean you want to burn a few
buildings kill a few people it's totally
fine
the guy doesn't know where he is well
you compare all of that to
really all you have in the m is kyle
rittenhouse who killed uh
violent felons and known child sex
offenders who were hitting him
with a skateboard and also had a gun
were aiming at his head so that's really
the comparison right now and if you go
to young turks or cnn they talk about
kyle rotten house
gunning down his victims but it show the
tape yeah yeah
gunning down his victims
but that's the young turks just show the
truth i don't no
no no we're having problems i don't know
i don't want to show the tape show the
tape went out and gun down victims just
show the tape
if we didn't have tape it would be
relevant but we do have tape which is
kind of why we film in the first place
that we generally film because we would
like to have yeah and we have it
is it useful listen it couldn't be more
clear if someone is telling you but here
is a good sign that someone is lying to
you
if someone is telling you about a story
in the news
where there is videographic evidence and
they don't show it
they're lying to you we've had this
happen with mashable on the verge where
they talked about me going up and
threatening the transgender at juice
juice land juice world right
i said why don't you just show the video
they had it at mashable and verge where
they said that we were selling uh
t-shirts that we had never sold in our
lives they talked about the videos where
we made false claims about black lives
matter at mass plus
listen why don't you show the video and
the lady said well i don't have enough
time to go through the whole video
will you reference the video just link
it you google it you type it in
and you it's a hyper delete that's all
you have to do take a look
and i wasn't and you're right we
shouldn't punch down at old demented
uh yes patients but i am i am a resident
of michigan
and we're allowed to go in and beat the
[ __ ] out of old people in our homes so
look there's our governor has governors
okay there's only a few states she's
given us for blessings they can
physically assault them and in new york
you can infect them
so but yeah the rest of the civilized
united states we need to treat our
elderly
and firm with care and compassion and
put them down do you say elderly
did you say elderly and firm like you
were coming on to an old person wow
wow elderly it's a fetish and it what
firm
some would say toned
oh experience
all the push-ups he's been doing
speaking of elderly yeah
uh and shooting straight and shooting
straight from the shoulder he said
straight from the shoulder
maybe that's what's going on he's punch
drunk let's go back to kamala harris
here because now they're saying donald
trump has not denounced the violence
uh he has repeatedly he's actually tried
to take proactive measures against the
violence you guys have funded the
violence which we will get to in a
second and i mean
many many many many many millions of
dollars funding directly
to these violent rioters violent felons
thugs in the streets
but first let's go back to uh you kamala
harris biden and broad
um by the way first half pos candidate
that's true poc that happy os candidate
uh talking about not only the riots the
protests at this point when they were
still referring to them as protests
would continue but they mentioned like
fermenting which really means
encouraging
right egging on violence here she is
actually telling them to continue on
stephen colbert a couple months ago
they're not no it's not they're not
gonna stop and that's they're not this
is a movement i'm telling you
they're not gonna stop and and everyone
beware
because they're not going to stop it is
going to they're not positive
election day in november and they're not
going to stop after election day
and that should be everyone should take
note of that on both levels
they're not gonna let up and they should
not and we should not
they shouldn't now i know somebody would
be saying hey is this before
there were there have been any right or
damage no this is still several it
wasn't 700 million or a billion in
property damage and like 18 deaths but
it was a handful of deaths
and a handful of billions yeah
and a few and a few hundred officers who
had been harmed at that point but
what broad worry yeah well she shouldn't
they shouldn't stop
yeah they shouldn't be aware this is the
new normal time out uh i thought they
came time out
they were yeah exactly i thought that if
they were elected that this would stop
she said
trump ramps up disinformation campaign
against we have to go to this look it's
a guy with uh dwight
to reveal here at some point in the
future i'm going to show you all the
all the evidence of it uh that never
comes and yet
you know he propagates this kind of
stuff i mean it's a pattern is it not
with the president
it's it's a long pattern this president
is a conspiracy theorist you know he
essentially entered a republican
life promoting this racist conspiracy
theory about barack obama's birthplace
he's promoted conspiracy theories about
windmills by the way the birther thing
was stupid but it wasn't racism it was
because of the claims that barack obama
had made about his birthplace
he had a conspiracy theory about ted
cruz they were inconsistent involved in
assassination
so he just he just does this and he's
doing it again yeah i mean
as you remind people there's something
they might have forgotten thanks cnn
against republicans too yeah
he's made a bunch of conspiracy by the
way trump made the quote
uh he made the statement that there are
people in the shadows i'll tell you some
of the daily
people in the shadows pulling the
strings uh and this is one thing that
donald trump
shoots from the hip um
uh and then sometimes doesn't think it
through let's get through where some of
the funding follow the money trail with
these riots because yes there's been a
lot of people out of state who've come
into riot and by the way that doesn't
really matter to leftists unless you're
carrying a firearm out of state then all
of a sudden borders matter
if you're showing up to burn down a
walgreens or a used car lot
you know listen we all have our flaws um
as long as you fill out your timesheet
as long as you
yeah good morning sam check in
so uh kamala harris um tweeted out a
link by the way to the
minnesota freedom fund asking people to
donate this is important we're talking
about people in the shadows the purse
rings 13 of joe biden's staff
also donated to the minnesota freedom
fund
um let's go through here who the
minnesota freedom from
freedom fund it's hard to say that's a
hard word minnesota freedom fund say it
minnesota freedom from minnesota freedom
i wish i worked ben shapiro sometimes
minnesota minnesota freedom bowling
ranch badges that helps oh help
it does help that's weird marriage when
you do tongue twister i'll just
bench appear so let's look at who the
minnesota freedom fund has set free
again no conspiracy theory needed we can
follow the money trail can we get a
shout out
for the hundred thousand dollars to
darnica floyd uh
stabbed a friend to death oh minnesota
freedom fund donated to
supported by the vice pres former vice
president presidential candidate joe
biden and broad kamala harris
first pos candidate half pos candidate
they uh paid minnesota freedom from 350
000
to free christopher boswell twice
convicted rapist
who currently is charged with assault
kidnapping and sexual assault in two
separate cases
oh no that's interesting they paid 75
000 let's get a ha ha
for jaleel stallings not to be confused
with jaleel white
yeah yeah oh a treasure national
treasure treasure yes
sullying the names of good jaleels
everywhere
did i do that no you didn't do this
this is a different one by the way you
don't need to try and be stefan don't
try so hard mr urkel
just be you jaleel stalling shot at
members of a swat team during the riots
in may
speedy gun and here's another one even
though the minnesota freedom fund was
not directly involved um the
catch-and-release approach is exactly
what led to the portland shooter
yes being free he'd already been
arrested for bringing in a loaded gun to
earlier protests and then he was
released
uh without being tried at all so when we
say fomenting violence because donald
trump and this is what they try and
corner them and say well why won't you
call it the kenosha shooter
because it's under investigation and by
the way it's also very different let's
just say
you really really hate conservatives you
really hate republicans and you really
hate kyle rittenhouse let's say that
kyle rittenhouse is a little prick right
never did a good thing in his life
here's the thing it is very very
different when you have
people who are armed with molotov
cocktails with guns who are burning down
businesses or assaulting unarmed people
and at the very least
kyle written house shooting people who
were armed when people said why did you
need a gun well
who did he shoot i got out of the gun
that's why he needed a gun so that does
change the scenario when two people have
guns regardless of where you line up
ideologically
that is not the same as the kind of
violence that has been taking place
against businesses innocent bystanders
and by the way yes
other civilians who probably would have
supported this movement only their
their house is being lit ablaze and the
paramedics and the fire department can't
get through because the cops have to
pave away
so let's be really clear they try and
catch donald trump on written house and
say
why haven't you condemned them well you
have actively donated and called
for other people to donate to multiple
times
convicted rapists and this is really
something my my half asian lawyers
always
charge charge allegedly i don't even
have to say that [ __ ] do i convicted
twice half asian bill am i wrong
look when there are multiple people with
the kind of background where you can
talk about
look at their convicted crimes and then
when you inform officers or people who
are being involved why isn't there a
denouncing that comes out for
the people who are causing this kind of
violence and the fact that
the that biden and his staff are out
there yeah i understand look there's
certain places counties cities states
where the bail program
is terrible but there's also a reason
why we have a program that says you got
to lock up violent people so they don't
go back out and shoot people in portland
right i will say i don't i don't support
like this idea of the three strike laws
that relates to the
violent drug offenders uh but i i do for
rapists
i think should be like one strike one i
think it should be one strike and you
are on very thin ice jaleel
you get a stern talking too you are
coming dangerously close to the line
yeah the one rape shame on me
and cnn has all this information two
rapes we cut your balls off oh boy
i think that's fair well i would
absolutely support the death i'm not
this is just personal opinion
i would absolutely support capital
punishment that's a crime to me
deserving of death for multiple time
rapists you give them you give them you
really should give them life these
people should not be free because the
recidivism rate is very high
uh depending on what the rape is sexual
assault domestic relationship but
violent rape
you do that twice i don't think i think
you forfeit your right to live
especially if it's a kid you would have
a strong argument
then yeah sexual assault against a child
to me is the kind of
people that knows no bounds not only is
it the kind of evil rape itself is evil
i know also republicans are supposed to
support rape right rape culture
but then we're also the ones who go out
and apparently are vigilantes against
rapists so
i don't know what how does that work not
only do i think that rape is an evil
crime
rape itself is an evil crime uh but then
you combine it with this perversion
this compulsive perversion of sexual
attraction to children
yeah where the rehabilitation rate is is
almost non-existent
in comparison to something like uh arson
or in comparison to something like you
know
theft you know sometimes people have a
sometimes people they they can't really
get out of their situation they steal
doesn't make it right
but once their situation changes and
they see the fruits of their labor
by living an honest life they no longer
steal doesn't really happen where all of
a sudden you take someone who's
attracted to
you know like the olsen twins circa full
house aaron what about christy blink
brinkley you're like no no no it doesn't
work for them those people
uh should not be allowed to be a part of
civil society exactly and anytime that
you can unite all of the murderers that
are currently in prison are like yeah
that's yeah they're like let's take that
guy out i know i killed 27 people and
ate half of them but that dude's messed
up
coming together right now he ate half he
was
pedophile
going back to the cnn thing right they
bend over backwards to show
you know the kyle written house like
you've seen the pictures of him holding
a weapon with great trigger discipline
right we just said that
he's not doing anything wrong and
they're like this is bad and then they
don't show an ant of a protester
or somebody else shooting another person
there because they're trump like they
don't show their mug shot
they don't show anything about them but
they're like this kyle guy he's he's a
dangerous fellow
he has a gun pointed at the ground
without his trigger on the there's a
militia out there and they're killing
people they're not
again just compare the numbers you're
talking about a billion dollars right
now the last number was 700 million i
know it's over a billion dollars
the numbers lag just like detroit under
reports murders
yeah because there's no one left to kill
yeah well oh but some hipsters open up
some coffee shops
you're gonna be raped
i take no joy in it i'm just staying
with you
there's no question that when you look
at the coverage that's by cnn
they're not interested in covering the
vice right no they're not
the only time they reference it every
day if you go and look
the only time they're referencing it is
so that they can go this this was trump
trump lit this building on fire yeah
metaphorically and biden's no better
biden calls out these trump-armed
militias and yet when he was asked to
remember the whole polling that came out
you've got to get these riots under
control and he said i condemn violence
of
every kind he bent over backwards not to
mention
rioters and antifa and black lives
matter and people that are actually
rioting and looting
you didn't mention them but you're like
of all kinds it's not a real thing
yeah of course it's not a real thing
let me ask that guy who uh killed hey
why'd you kill that guy
100 beyond with no shadow of a doubt
antifa
i am 100 percent antifa yeah it doesn't
seem like he settled on his story
yet i'll get back to you all right back
to you no no no no
100 yeah he doesn't know what he's
saying somebody get this guy he has no
idea what he's talking about
oh and black lives matter saying
something about i don't know oval team
the guy's out of his mind
he's out because of jobs he needs a job
that's right give him a job
he's a model just like climate change is
the reason for isis
this is the logic that you see from the
left today no that wasn't actually i
know i know but it's been hot there
forever come on
donald trump's interview if you haven't
watched it with laura ingram yesterday i
don't know if you guys watched the full
interview where he's talking to me
listen the green new deal okay would
take a hundred trillion dollars and if
you read the green new deal it's
it's from the mind of a child that's
what it is
and that is completely descriptive that
is 100 descriptive i have never heard a
president before donald trump in an
interview or national address
frankly stupid people he says that
stupid people he is the best
trash-talking president we've ever had
he's a heel he's a heel he really is
what he's doing in the nba he's that guy
that's like
shawn at you the entire game and then
the fourth quarter you just lose your
mind which is happening
come on yes right now some people think
that it it belittles the officer it's
below the office i think it would
improve every great speech it's like uh
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
and stupid people
oh that means what but he's he's shoring
on wings of an eagle on that wheelchair
with that that rhetoric at times you
need guys like him and he's exactly like
churchill in that regard he pissed
everybody off for not saying the right
stuff yeah he just posted and then
churchill was immediately ejected
because he didn't support a nationalized
healthcare plan so this is what happens
keep us safe protect us and then give us
free stuff give us free stuff but we had
to spend a lot of money
on making sure that you're not all
speaking german we're in funny patches
we want free [ __ ] now okay i'll see my
way out bye
all right uh we're going to be right
back actually so we have a sponsor to go
to okay
i believe so i'm not entirely sure how
the sponsor works but i want to hear
from you do you really find it
convincing at all
the biden the harris blaming the
violence on trump and do you think he'll
be safer
in trump's america that vines america he
asked that question i answered yes
absolutely without i with no hesitation
absolutely i think we'll be less safe
with uh biden as president
um and we'll be back with uh after the
sponsor i changed my mind from
it's what is it it's um it's paco the
friendly homophobe spot i don't know how
that works
oh for a message from paco the friendly
homophobe
that's me okay thank you ma'am you can
pass on through
all right next come on up hands out
legs open okay come through
please hold all right sir do you mind if
i pat down your right leg
and inner thigh you don't don't want you
have to do
it's your job i understand yes thank you
very much so i'm going to
pat here you don't have to do
what do you mean sir i saw the other guy
he told you i was okay to clearly go
through
but you are the one who told me you
still have to pay my leg
i don't follow you're not patting my leg
because
you want to not because it is your job
and you want to pat my leg unlike the
blonde before me nice lady who
you let us do without any pad now
because you are not straight
[Laughter]
what will he what yeah wacky scenario
will he find himself in that
friendly guy though such a very very guy
very likely
likable he knows it's wrong to hate such
a calm demeanor yeah
[Laughter]
resume between hate and for some people
intense discomfort sure
that's true it's cultural i i was
sexually harassed by a uh
wardrobe guy yeah i've talked about this
and i it didn't bother me like but i can
understand that if i were a woman and if
it were a much bigger stronger man but
he would just be like
oh you're you're uh you're cute i'm just
gonna i'm gonna clean up your
little buns like oh yeah those jeans you
know you should think about wearing
lower rise jeans kind of like he would
talk about my
like i was a p like i was a piece of
what's his name scudo
[Laughter]
and that was and i thought he i didn't
hate the man but i was uncomfortable
with him um grabbing my buttocks
all right it is time now uh we're going
to be talking about the polls after when
we go
uh of course exclusively dot com slash
but right now
the many of you have asked me uh this
have you ever changed your mind anything
and to be clear
that's not re the reason for change my
mind is to
present your position in the affirmative
and allow other people to make an
argument and that's because a lot of
people are busy trying to score points
and the idea for change of mind is to
listen to someone make their case that
being said
i have changed my mind on a subject
really ah
tesla's let's go
[Music]
all right now do we have the montage
that tim put together from hr no we
don't okay
all right that was where you would say
you pulled some clips of me saying it
was in the teaser
oh it was the teaser okay of the teslas
okay let me be really clear here
uh i have spoken in the past about uh
how this is where that montage would
come in handy where
right i wasn't a big fan of electric
cars tesla's in general now let me be
really clear
where i have not changed my mind a lot
of traffic arguments
the arguments still stand in that
electric cars
are not better for the environment than
buying a used car okay
the best thing you can do is buy a used
beater and drive it into the ground you
don't need a new tesla
and if you go and you look at these
lithium ion batteries depending which
ones they are
mining for these very difficult to put
together minerals
and they're they basically sit in the
earth for a very long time
right now it is and by the way your
electricity comes from somewhere
coal some places that's that's kind of
that's reductive
sorry but clean coat it does typically
where does your energy come from where
you are
it could come from gas natural gas it
could come from coal
uh in quebec it came from hydroelectric
which is apparently a problem here
because of an endangered species of fish
i don't get it
it's just water moving you saw swiss
family robinson i don't know how
anyone's against it
now i am also still against subsidies in
general i want to be really clear and
there it has been a lot of subsidization
for electric cars and yes tesla is a
company that would not exist
if not force up my mind has not changed
on that also
i still maintain that most electric cars
this is where there's an exception
tesla's not withstanding but most
electric cars
are still pretty gay so okay
uh by the way hit the notification bell
if you want more of this uh because
every morning you know you get a
notification now
if you were ever worried about us being
able to do youtube
yeah it's the time to sign up for mud
club
you can't find a straight man driving a
prius uh
what do you mean ah don't don't you i
know just don't try and be a guy really
you know a guy
how well do you know the guy i rest my
case okay
so well well he knows very well
he knows him inside and
[Laughter]
tell me more gerald tell me more no i
won't more did you
get very far uh-huh uh-huh i'm gay and
you're singing the musical really
ah everyone knows what's happening here
okay
so let me hit this now what has changed
i am against subsidies and tesla has
received a lot of subsidies but
let me be really clear here because when
i had to reflect upon all of this right
tesla is basically an american-based car
maker right
yeah we have to compare them to the
marketplace now tesla has received
directly 0.4 billion dollars in
subsidies okay
not a big fan of that but they did pay
it all
back early with interest so now if we
compare that to the big three
right gm chrysler ford they received
just in 2008 and that's not the first
bailout
80 billion dollars alone and the
taxpayer is still on the hook for nine
billion of those dollars so that's more
that's a big 80 billion dollars there's
a gap there compared to nine billion and
i do think this is important because
the bailout was given to the big three
uh american car companies yeah when they
were
losing market share because they had
mismanaged their businesses they had
these crazy union pensions whereas tesla
received these subsidies while they were
creating a new market
and expanding their market share so
there is a difference with a new
technology right and the government
saying okay this might be beneficial in
the long term if it's a loan that is
paid back
which it had been and is creating new
markets because that will actually
create new jobs
that loan allowed tesla to employ more
americans
whereas uh the bailout to gm nine
billion of which uh still were on the
hook for
thanks barack obama uh actually just
maintains employment and retiree
benefits for people who don't do any
work yeah really really
really bad union so so that is important
i think it's also important you know
listen this
this is the result of too big to fail
now in a perfect world no car companies
would be receiving bailouts okay no car
companies are receiving
loans but it's really hard to create a
car company
in the 21st century when uh they're
receiving
it's just like you can't create a new
airline right they're receiving hundreds
of millions and billions of dollars over
time
because the government says well they're
too big to fail just like the banks well
what should really happen is the bank
should fail and then local state banks
should become national banks right local
credit unions they should be able to do
a little bit better
the same thing with cars oh you
mismanaged it well
now daewoo gets a shot only in this case
no they've already had this it was it's
tesla right
it's it's tesla it's really hard to
compete against the big boys just like
opening up a bank you're not going to
compete with bank of america
so the fact that with only 1.4 billion
or 400 million i'm sorry i can't do it
what four is 400 million 400 that's fine
well i just
was compared to 80 billion i know i'm
sorry people are here 80
million as opposed to 80 billion and
points yeah you did i did there you go
thank you for asking the question but
you didn't know the answers
i i think that's one of the things that
is important to focus on is the question
of where
do where does government assistance play
a role in making sure that america
can right compete on the world stage
especially when you consider
the legacy of the big three in america i
mean
the the fact that they made poor
decisions that led them to where they
are and certainly
i'm not saying there aren't some
external factors but a lot of it came
down to
poor planning poor prognostication about
a particular industry and getting too
bloated
and leading to needing to be supported
in a way that is just
outsized for what they're providing and
yet when we need to try and create
these kinds of businesses compare an
american car manufacturer to what you
can do in rural china
i mean besides releasing viruses you can
do anything out there
i mean you can literally do anything
from here make it sound like
david copperfield rehearsing with doves
go
go be free infect the worm
yeah and so and so when you look at look
at those other countries that are
competing and it's not just even
uh asian car brands right they're
european car brands that are also
relying on
right other third world countries to
provide or rural areas like in china
to provide the vehicles and provide the
technology and provide the other things
that are giving them an advantage
against american businesses so when it
comes to trying to create a nascent
car industry i can see the idea about
why we would want to make sure we can
foster that in the u.s
yeah but the point is you didn't need to
because tesla was there all along and it
could have been occurring at ludicrous
speed
a little inside joke where they could
have advanced but it's really hard for
them to compete and grab a market share
here's another point that i want to get
to but i do agree with your argument
there and i do think that someone needs
to examine in general i'm against
bailouts
um tesla now people will argue that
they've been more subsidized in the form
of a 7 500
tax credit and that is true where for
electric vehicles basically you get a 7
500
tax credit and in a way that's basically
effectively a subsidy but it's different
because it's not just
a one-time bit like 80 billion dollar
bailout right it's basically being
subsidized
uh through each car sold because they
see value in this technology
compared to let's say old gas schedulers
now i do i'm against that i am against
that again
0.4 billion dollars and then 7500 for
cars
here's the thing though here's the
kicker tesla getting 7500 tax credits so
is gm
so sport every electric car manufacturer
gets
the 7 500 tax credit so it's not a leg
up from tesla
it's just the same competition the same
level competition field only it's worse
than that
because tesla has actually generated
electric vehicles and this is really
what it comes down to
that people want to buy oh as opposed to
whatever it is the
the volt the bolt there's the in the
bolt you think the volt is the electric
but i think the bolt is a non-electric
and the bolt is electric
i don't know what it is there's the leaf
horrible cars they receive
7 500 as well tesla doesn't get any more
because once they sell
200 000 electronic vehicles yeah that
credit goes away
so because tesla has been successful
despite paying back the loan with
interest and gm ford chrysler have not
fully paid back the loan
they've sold 200 000 units and now they
no longer get that subsidy from the
government that tax credit
but gm because they've been making
shitty electric cars that nobody wants
still get that same tax credit so
they're still to this day
receiving more subsidization from the
federal government so i did have to look
at that again i am totally against
bailouts i'm totally against
supporting and propping up businesses
that don't deserve it in the first place
however
you do have to live in the real world
and understand ultimately
since we have given these ballots is it
better or worse for american consumers
and for people who are working in the
american manufacturing sector
to have another company who can compete
and pay back these loans with interest
and do it on a buy as you go
so that is one thing um that uh i
actually will tell you
has changed my mind on the teslas but
you know the main reason that's good did
you remember my tesla
uh i've written tim's tesla here from hr
my wife actually got you know the gbs
and so
um it was really hard it's hard for her
to drive right now and so i was looking
for this sort of auto pilot features and
i was looking at ford and i was looking
at the the korean cars
and then i was had to look uh higher
scale where they said actually the auto
driver was really much better at bmw and
mercedes and then someone said have you
really just looked into a tesla it's not
even close
oh wow so i tried driving a tesla it is
it's pretty damn cool
so what do you drive so fun to drive
where that wasn't the case back when it
was like i had a friend who had a prius
he was gay in sydney valley uh drove the
priest but i know it's not fully
electric but it was like driving a
shopping cart even with that one fourth
wheel that goes
what the hell why can't you get a cart
that works uh compared to the tesla it
is more fun than
any car i've ever driven nice uh and the
autopilot is incredible so it does make
sense to get from my wife you can do the
one pedal driving but even more than
that
what convinced me and i want to know
where you line up here on tesla's uh
if this has maybe changed your mind a
little bit or provided some context was
not only did i drive
them but when the hodge twins were here
for a week yeah um
i drove with them and uh and so i i
then i i bought one immediately here
you'll see why
[Music]
god
[Music]
hodgman's first time on a test uh audio
wade's first time on a tesla too right
got some tesla actually going i don't
know if a tesla has exactly
the same zip as mclaren
but it's pretty good
we were going 80. what
if you touch the car icon you can
actually turn that zipping this up
bottom left oh yeah oh was it not uh
driving mode oh you had it you didn't
have it turned up this whole time
what's the matter colonel sanders
chickens so that was slow
that was on slow um what kind of axles
this damn thing got
so look at our axes
[Music]
yeah i'm about two inches taller
i feel like i got some giraffe action
going oh my god
i'm on my neck
help mama right
man two drops of p came out
they don't even feel like you on the
ground though people have died owning
teslas
i mean the thing is like look okay we're
going we're already going 80. yeah
yeah and then you just if i even at the
high gear if i just tap it
we just went to 100. what the
that is crazy this is the way of the
future
i don't i usually i'm okay with being
pulled over but
all right here let's see i'm going to
get in a lane and i'll try the autopilot
and then we'll let you know man i think
my heart
going to do this again okay so look
hands off
what do you think i should trust it
going around this curve yeah
i would
stay in the lane though look it's
showing me all the cars around me on the
side
and see the same thing it doesn't drive
as aggressively obviously if you uh
right but if i do i think this one does
if i hit the flasher
it says i can't because there's a car oh
son of a [ __ ]
oh that's bryce
we're trying to get in the left lane
right here you know i'll pull into the
parking lot here
and then uh one of you guys can who
wants to grab the
[Music]
look i wheel eight i went to 75. that
was in
three that was in like less than two
seconds
about it i can't wait till this drill
ride's over you wanna drive
i don't trust myself in this car man go
ahead and drive it kevin
you're gonna go gonna be a lot sick so
keith you're gonna drive
yeah are you kevin yeah who said keith
was driving up keith
who's gonna drive keith are you confused
come on you know this [ __ ] happens all
the time
hey siri you have [ __ ] trying to
drive
let me see the real let me see some rear
view camera action
you gotta do it again i don't think
that's it on top
crabbing the road huh yeah i'm liking it
man it feels like i'm flying and getting
sick to my stomach
that guy that tells me you're going to
jail
hey man you're going too damn fast man
still they feel like a comment for like
a
let me get some driving action just feel
like some wakanda
grabbing around i don't know if you know
this but all of africa would be like
wakanda
if not for the united states yeah we
stole all their skyscrapers and
technology on ships
obama did they did
pull it twice yeah pull it twice see the
blue now let go
you just kind of lightly touch the wheel
but you see the blue steering wheel in
front of you yeah
that means it's on no no you put your
you want to keep your hands down lightly
no no it's going to be good for us my
heart's beating
it lightly touch the wheel it's going to
natural right
here hit the flasher to go in the left
lane yeah they ain't doing that
get the flash to stop flashing man
this is i gotta touch the wheel touch
with you i'm just grabbing the wheel all
right
if you tap the brake it'll just tap the
brake lightly it'll back up
talking about right here
hey man what you doing man you feel that
feeling hey keith man you getting an
accident man it's being recorded live
hey man would you take it easy on the
gas man i mean on the electricity yeah
whatever it is
that's right you stay don't run on gas
big ass duracell
i'm gonna go buy me one of them duracell
so you're gonna
pull the bottom there you go there we go
and now you can let go and it'll ask you
to touch the wheel lightly every now and
then
i don't know why this is some robot
action
will it hurt when you will
you ain't asking the right question
that my friend is the right question so
i think it's i think we just get out i
think it'll turn off
[Music]
and there you have it uh my mind was
changed i don't know if all of you have
uh
two biracial uh hilarious comedians at
the ready
uh but it helps and i wanna know what
you think with the tesla
uh electric cars in general has any of
this changed your opinion when you put
it in context of subsidization and the
fact that elon musk has created some
really pretty cool
cars and looks like a small child so
elon i hope you enjoy the stock prices
soaring it's entirely
due to this program i've changed my mind
tesla's next installment will be
weed i can already see the comments
coming
oh that was fun yeah hodge twins they're
just like that all those guys
i love these they're like walking
cartoons incredible do you know they
live in town in a town home together
a split town one bathroom
yeah when they're here they go to the
same bathroom
they use the same bathroom at the same
time we have two bathrooms
right next to each other right next to
each other
that's a bit messy yeah i don't know i
haven't waited
footage that makes you weird see going
to the bathroom
is a natural function watching a guy
going
to watch anybody yeah well then how
could he confirm it
all right well listen hey we're going to
go to the polls with some surprising
numbers that have come out recently uh
particularly from uh
i know rasmussen people say oh rashford
well they still have clinton winning the
last election and now emerson
college has a new poll uh we're going to
be talking about that exclusively
and taking your chat uh at
lyderworthcutter.com
mug club live on the blaze right now
youtube we appreci
piss off